even though Marvel has not technically
confirmed that a black widow movie is
coming we know it's confirmed thanks to
some leaked set photos and videos and
although we don't really know much about
the movie today we have a plot leak that
seems very legitimate that describes a
part of the movie how's it going
everyone it's Warren and I'm gonna break
down everything you need to know about
this black widow plot leaked in this
video also if you would like to win a
Captain America shield and Iron Man
helmet and Infinity Gauntlet or another
Marvel Legends item be sure to subscribe
to my channel I'm doing a giveaway at
four hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers I'll be picking three
winners so a couple of days ago an
author for Marvel Studios
uploaded a book to Amazon and then
quickly took it down after this author
has written many books about the MCU
that are canon meaning even though they
happen in a book and not in a movie the
effects of the book still affect what
happens in the MCU so like I said the
author uploaded it and then quickly
deleted it after but luckily for us
reddit user popcorn panther saw it
before it was deleted and has reposted
it to reddit the name of the book is
Black Widow the hero's journey and is
set after the events of Civil War the
part that was uploaded reads Natasha
Romanoff the lethal super spy known as
Black Widow is locked in a room with
Berlin's Joint Terrorism Task Force
playing cat-and-mouse with agent Everett
Ross she's wondering if Ross has any
idea why she agreed to come in he's
wondering a lot of things what possessed
her to let Steve Rogers Captain America
escape from the Berlin aircraft hangar
with fugitive Bucky Barnes whose orders
did she follow where is Rogers now we
then have an actual picture of two pages
of the book that give us more details
and they read shifting his weight from
his right foot to his left foot Ross
stared into the conference room across a
small table and into the direct
laser-focused gaze of Natasha Romanov
Black Widow her red hair framed her face
as she looked at Ross almost impassive
Ross started to speak again I'm sorry
about the heat he added almost
apologetically air conditioners on the
fritz I keep asking them to fix it but
well you know the government Natasha's
red lips parted in a non-committal smile
she had learned long ago never to betray
what she was thinking
I'm fine she said still smiling with an
impressive operation like this you'd
think you could afford something
Ross shrugged we don't have the budget
we're not exactly shield he said then
again shield isn't exactly shield
anymore is it
Natasha raised an eyebrow deciding that
she should let Ross believed that his
off-the-cuff dig caught her off-guard
once it was learned that Hydra had been
operating from within shield for decades
manipulating events the strategic
homeland intervention enforcement and
logistics division had essentially
fallen apart as far as Natasha was
concerned that was the distant past if
Ross had been hoping to unnerve her or
keep her off balance he was going to
have to do better a lot better
I've been interrogated by experts she
thought experts with even worse air
conditioning you want to know what
happened at the airport Natasha finally
prompted him breaking the uncomfortable
silence that had developed Ross clapped
his hands together yes the airport what
happened at the airport I followed my
orders Natasha replied coolly your
orders Ross said sharply were to
apprehend Rogers and Barnes those were
Tony Starks orders Natasha corrected my
orders were to stop them from reaching
the hangar I did that Ross stared at
Natasha unblinking seriously
Natasha arched an eyebrow again you
stopped them from reaching the hangar
then you stepped aside let them enter
the hangar board a Quinn jet and take
off I let them go if that's what you're
after Natasha stated Ross bit his lower
lip what part of stop didn't you
understand
Natasha tilted her head and looked back
at Ross the smile never left her face so
again according to the Reddit user this
was posted on Amazon but was quickly
taken down after which obviously leads
us to the question why was this taken
down
we know that the Black Widow movie is
going to be a prequel but we don't
exactly know when it's going to take
place and the movie could also jump
around into several different parts of
Natasha Romanovs life so perhaps we may
finally see what happens to natasha
romanoff after the events of civil war
we do know that she goes on the run with
Steve Rogers after so perhaps we'll see
that take place so this could be related
to the Black Widow movie this could be
something that we'll see but this also
could just be a canon book that is
coming out so take this with a grain of
salt so let me know what you think about
this and let me know if this is
something that you would like to see in
the Black Widow movie leave your
thoughts in the comments down below also
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like the
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf